[Music]
big star movies seem to come with a
motto that says you'll get a tear for
every laugh but there seemed to have
been way more tears than laughs watch
until the end for the biggest tearjerker
of them all can you guess which one it
will be don't forget to hit that
notification valve to never miss another
video and be sure to check out our
community section for even more fun now
let's check out 10 Pixar movies
guaranteed to make you cry Finding Nemo
okay let's start light you guys although
there really isn't such a thing as light
when it comes to fix our movies Finding
Nemo it's a perfect story about
helicopter parents and children
struggling with independence and finding
their own path it's one of those things
most of us can definitely relate to of
course all of this is masked in an
absolutely adorable underwater movie
that comes with plenty of sentimental
moments first of all almost every scene
with dory will make you cry if you're in
the right mood how sad must be to
actually have a memory so bad you can't
even remember your family or how about
the moment when Nemo says to his dad
that it's okay to let go this is one of
those movies where adults might find it
way more sentimental than kids who knew
that a story about a fish could actually
make us cry our eyes out so let's keep
swimming because we have way more
tear-jerking movies to cover finding
Dory seriously everyone was waiting for
this movie to come out and it was well
worth it when it did Dory charm to so
many people Pixar decided to give her
her own big screen movie and of course
it came with plenty of sentimental
moments the fact that Dory's parents
actually searched for her when she so
helplessly tried to find them in the
first movie is actually pretty sad it's
even worse when you realize that it
really was Dory's fish memories fault
that she got separated from her parents
to begin with you would think her family
actually treated her badly because they
couldn't find her but as it turns out
she had a lovely childhood this is also
one of those movies adults will
appreciate more than children regardless
of the childhood you've had who would
have thought that a little blue animated
fish could make us feel such things the
movie comes with some hard-hitting
moments that will
definitely leave you choked up and if
this one doesn't we have eight more to
go and one of them definitely will make
you cry your eyes out Monsters Inc uh
how could we possibly not talk about
Monsters Inc sure it does come with
plenty of moments that will make you
laugh out loud let's be honest this
movie can definitely make you cry too
Pixar really knows how to make the
endings really really sad before we get
our final closure when such ending is
without a doubt the scene where Sully
says goodbye to booth it's one of our
favorite Pixar moments ever and it still
makes us cry every single time it's
absolutely heartbreaking when Sully
realizes he can never see boo again but
honestly you probably cried when Sully
sends boo back to her room kitty has to
go has to be one of the most
heart-wrenching Pixar sentences ever and
we still cry every time we hear it
maybe that's why Pixar decided to put
several Easter eggs in the scene they
probably knew we'd all be bawling our
eyes out
well played Pixar well played it's even
worse when you realize you won't get any
closure because boo doesn't return for
monsters University seriously we just
want to know how this kid is doing Pixar
is that too much to ask
[Music]
brave Merida might be seen as a tough
Disney princess but there are plenty of
scenes in brave that can really make you
cry let's start with the fact that
Merida is actually one of the first
Disney Princesses that doesn't need a
man to have her own princess story
that's pretty impressive for Disney
right but most people can identify with
Merida and the bond she shares with her
mother her mother's not so pleased with
her daughter's so-called tomboyish ways
but they still have a strong bond but
one of the most tearjerker moments comes
when Merida announces she'll never ever
be like her mother it starts with an
arguments many of us have heard before
Merida even cuts a rift through the
family's tapestry of course most Pixar
movies have a happy ending but let's be
honest this movie really did make us
think about our own relationships with
our mothers and whether they're good or
bad this is the moment where most of us
were without a doubt sobbing Merida's
words were definitely something we
wanted to say to Pixar really knows how
to make the most heart-wrenching scenes
doesn't it bow-bow isn't technically a
full-length Pixar movie but since it's a
short we're adding it
- you could catch this eight-minute
short in the new Incredibles - and it's
definitely one of those that will make
all mother sob it might be assured about
dumplings but it's definitely a
tearjerker bowel is all about a Chinese
mom who gets another chance at
motherhood when one of her dumpling
springs to life everything is fine and
cute until she realizes that even sweet
little dumplings have to eventually grow
up you can see where this is going right
many have praised the movie and
expressed how it touched them and made
them think about their relationship with
their mom it's one of those shorts that
will really hit you in the fields and it
doesn't help it's followed by the highly
anticipated sequel to The Incredibles
either fix are really nailed it with
this one it seems like they really only
need eight minutes to come up with
something that will make us tear up cars
three we can pinpoint plenty of moments
from previous two cars movies that could
make you cry but the third one is where
you really need your tissues when the
Cars 3 trailer came out it was
criticized as being far too traumatic
for kids to be fair it was pretty harsh
seeing Lightning McQueen go down like
that cars is one of those movies that
gets you all pumped up but that crash
scene is by far the most heart-wrenching
scene we have ever seen on top of that
seeing sterling say Lightning is
incapable of winning was a very real
moment for anyone who's ever been
doubted in cars franchise gets you so
pumped up to cheer for your fav who's
been working so hard but more than often
something ends up happening to that fave
that completely breaks your heart don't
worry we've been there two cars three is
just one of those movies where you'll
cry at the beginning and the end - we're
pretty sure you won't be able to resist
a tear that was cars 3 the final two the
franchise or will we cry even more in
the next one Toy Story 3 let's be honest
Toy Story 3 was just playing with our
emotions throughout the movie seriously
it's by far one of the most
heart-wrenching Pixar movies ever well
the fourth most heart-wrenching Pixar
movie ever because we still have three
more to go when we watched Andy let go
of his beloved toys we all weeped
and it brought back memories to our own
favorite childhood toys most of us left
behind the furnace teen also hits you
with a full force as you watch the toys
embrace the fact of what's about to
happen to them it's one of the most
terrifying Pixar scenes
ever and we're pretty sure nothing will
ever be able to top it at least we hope
it won't because we never want to go
through these same emotions ever again
but watching Andy give away his toys and
realizing he's finally growing up is
something we just can't accept it's even
worse when you realize that you grew up
with the Toy Story franchise and by the
looks of it and you grew up with you too
Oh Pixar why are you doing this to us
but get ready because we're about to
explore our top three biggest Pixar
tearjerkers up how could we possibly
forget about up let's be honest when it
comes to saddest Pixar movies up is the
best one or in our case the third best
one don't worry we'll get there
Pixar really knows how to make sure you
cry unexpectedly when it comes to most
movies you can easily cry at the end or
in the middle but only Pixar can make
you cry at the beginning this is
precisely how up starts with a
tear-jerking moment of introducing Ellie
and Carl's story it's the set up to the
entire movie and why Carl acts the way
he acts it's actually surprising Pixar I
wanted to cut this exact scene out of
the movie because it was almost too real
for its audience of course there are
plenty of other touching moments that
can really get you going later on but
the beginning of the movie really sets
off the entire atmosphere for the story
it's one of those scenes that will
really touch adults more than it will
kids seriously tissues are needed for
this one no matter how many times you
have seen it before we're tearing up
just thinking about Ellie and Carl's
life story wall-e
yep we're putting wall-e before up can
you believe it
Pixar can really make you cry when you
watch a movie about anything dumplings
cars robots it doesn't matter
they're really able to create stories
that are totally relatable even though
they're told by things that aren't
necessary people wall-e is one of those
Pixar movies that will make you
unexpectedly weep as you reach the
ending we won't give too much away if
you haven't seen it but let's just say
that the ending is honestly unexpected
if you thought Sully leaving boo behind
was sad you're definitely not ready for
what's about to happen to this robot
what makes wall-e even more
heart-wrenching than any other movie is
the fact that it doesn't really feature
a lot of dialogue it really made
pay attention and then hits you in the
fields as hard as ever
seriously Pixar really knows how to make
movies weathers with a dialog or without
wall-e is definitely a tearjerker that
you should add to your to watch list but
it's still not the saddest Pixar movie
ever there's a new kid on the block that
will really make you cry your eyes out
ready Coco did you guess it we just had
to put Coco on the top of the list Coco
is totally a different movie from
anything Pixar has ever created it shows
much more history and it's completely
dedicated to a single culture but
there's a particular scene in Coco
that's even worse than the furnace scene
in Toy Story 3 Coco will give you some
serious Bambi fills and we can guarantee
you're not going to be ready for it the
entire movie is a true reminder that we
should definitely live our life to the
fullest because you never know when it's
going to end but what makes Coco so sad
is the fact that there isn't just one
tear-jerking scene out there there are
quite a few seriously if you haven't
seen Coco you need to add it to your
list and bring a box of tissues and a
person you love with you too we just
can't wait to see what Pixar will create
next but whatever it is we're truly
ready to cry our eyes out once again in
your opinion what's the saddest Pixar
moment ever let us know in the comments
and that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]